good morning believe nation today's
message is rediscover yourself over to
you ar-rahman what is modernist
rediscovering yourself rediscovering the
way music is done as modern I do love to
embrace new technology and new ideas and
especially like in the film like Slumdog
where Danny suggested mi ma as someone
you know interpretation of music and
everything so it was like a two cultures
meeting in the way like some of the
people who are very close - I say oh
what are they doing is just noise
rappers noise and heavy metal it's noise
so when you go into that frame of you
just try to like for what like something
for what it is not you know go take a
lens and disrupt it and try to analyze
it so with this philosophy I think I
kept moving on for like eight years
rediscovering oh I see so I rediscover
myself every day every single day even
just through this YouTube channel I
rediscover myself I started this channel
one of the main reasons was I wanted to
learn myself I wanted a better
environment for myself I wanted to
surround myself with people who've done
more than I've done and learn from them
and every time I make a top 10 video and
in spresso video believe life you do any
of the videos that I put out three times
a day I put them out because I've
learned something from them when
somebody says a message I take it and I
try not to be like them the goal isn't
to be like that person it's the better
version of ourselves and when they give
you that message think about how it's
gonna impact your life I was gonna
impact your business how can you apply
it some way if you're just consuming
content and you don't apply it anywhere
it's not a good use of time it's a great
mental exercise I guess but nothing else
is gonna change in your life until you
take action what's really interesting is
a lot of the lessons are the same from
the musicians we've covered in athletes
and entrepreneurs and inventors and
politicians a lot of the messages are
the same a lot of the messages for
success
are the same but hearing it consistently
I find helps if you are not getting the
results that you want if you have these
big goals and you're nowhere close to
them and you don't see that happening in
the next you know a few weeks months
years if you're not making the progress
towards it if you feel you have that
untapped potential you don't know how to
go and accomplish it it's likely because
you have a poor mindset from your
parents and the people around you from
your neighborhood from your environment
you have a poor mindset that holds you
where you are and the way to break free
of it is to surround yourself with
people who have a better mindset a more
empowering mindset a more impactful
mindset and so I do it by hanging around
these successful entrepreneurs every
single day I don't have the people
physical people that I can go and talk
to who pushed me to be better I get it
by watching these videos and so I
challenge you to think if you're not
getting your goals look at your
environment and see if you're doing the
right things and yes a lot of these
messages will be the same consistently
over and over and over again but hearing
it from somebody else in the words that
they use sometimes that's the trigger
and unit consistently helps break free
of the poor mind set to go off and
accomplish bigger things and sometimes
it's just an issue of timing you may
have heard the message before but for
some reason today you're ready to hear
it and to actually take some action on
it if you want to do big things if you
want to accomplish a big goal then you
have to be continually rediscovering
yourself and if you're not doing it
you're gonna stay where you are
so I encourage you pick up the mantle
take some action so the question that
today is I'm curious what do you do on a
consistent basis to rediscover yourself
leave it down the comments below super
curious to find out I also want to give
a quick shout out to on J Martin Andre
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word really really
really means a lot to me and I hope
you're enjoying the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much loved and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of an
espresso
[Music]
first we all have to set goals for
ourselves I mean our planning
destination is to be busy and to you
know adjust to whatever you whatever you
introduced to and what I mean by that is
okay as an entertainer I started off as
a singer you know I grew to become a
dancer and a performer
after becoming a performer then I became
an actor after becoming an actor I
became an entrepreneur to become an
entrepreneur I became an entertainer on
a different level of introducing other
artists then you know after that I
became a mentor you know so I think just
to continue to evolve in a way that is
beneficial for growth of myself and
others my likeness to continue to be
remembered throughout history and
associated with something great for me
you know there's a there's a mantra that
I've I've lived by and it is that the
journey of the destination is really
what it's all about the pursuit is more
important than the actual destination so
as long as you are moving as long as
you're working that is the destination
Wow yeah the journey but really it is
simply that the journey is the
destination I agree as long as you're
working you're you're good as a writer
you start trying different things and
you try different chords or different
structures of songs different beats that
you've never really explored that path
before you know and I think having
always been a writer first I'm obsessed
with the syncopation of the way that
words sound when they're said a certain
way and once I've kind of done something
once I always want to go to a different
direction and and never repeat myself so
as a writer I think that I've always
hoped that my music would constantly be
changing because you never want to make
the same album twice the same song twice
and you know my greatest hope has been
that as I grow my fans will grow up with
me and as I change and my life changes
my music will change as well so extreme
team Minaj says I love you but I'm
curious why did you change your rapping
style from the come-up days to today I
love both I don't think I changed my rap
style um I think you guys were just
starting to hear me and you didn't hear
all of me yet that's it I've always been
into being weird a little bit but I
think what people really mean is that
they think that I've changed my persona
and and life is about growth and change
and I don't want to remain the same for
my whole life I want to be able to
change and you know I respect the people
who loved you know oh seven Nikki and
I'm definitely gonna give you some stuff
and on pink Friday like I'm not
forgetting anybody but I just also have
to be true to me
and the truth is I started seeing
different things I started going
different places I started eating
different things I can't I it would be
fraudulent to to rap the same way and
look the same way I act the same way
because I am not the same